vous
ici pour la soirée c
c'est 4e
à mon lolo a ravi le raymond sala temps
les dinos pour ça va bien merci
qu'est ce qu'il à votre pied droit qui
me crie des problèmes comme andy gill à
zurich si il est mal aux pieds voilà
venaient à pied près du lac saint malo
tiens je veux penser comme un chaton
manger dans ce secteur
1,1 ça c'est du talent
a bola par la ligue 1 ce soir on taffe
un dîner aquarium le riche en hommage à
ton fils et cela paie mais c'est vrai
qu'on dit houle sa maison ses parents
venus début des travaux toi non non je
vais pas retombée chez place est bien
leader avec la pièce c'est la pièce à la
porte du blé comme le tf travail on
aurait pu mettre aux gambas quand vous
voyez pas dedans allez on y va on dirait
mon jeu wen tong on regarde au nom va
pas tout si vous mettiez ballon tu
connais carlos voilà carlos maître
capello le célèbre maître capello
contingenté charles voilà aïcha charlie
francis dit le roi juan carlos est idiot
c'est le chant chamelle jean-charles
mais les gens sont cons où ils ont
conclu le prince william s'est dit le
prince guillaume bien sûr wallonne
france françois jacq alors je fais un
nouveau livre ce moment près de mou qui
se croisent
c'est à dire de vous croiser ici et ça
comprend une défense à ceux ci
verbicruciste haine et non pas et
gestion c'est crazy verbist 15 attaques
un problème dit qu'on ferait je vais
dire un cette occurrence en cette
occurrence dans cette occurrence [ __ ]
c'est moi qui avais raison c'est moi qui
ai même toit soyons bref mais précis
raison il continua pas dit que nous que
les raisons et les raisons et surtout un
point c'est tout c'est tout alors le
problème ces occurrences à jacques je
joue les 2 c et 2 rbds
il a mis de ces deuxièmes
merci welsh mjs avait un verrier ce pas
de problème et rend faute et l'a vérifié
ou 6 sauf au dessus en cette occurrence
gilbert de celle ci la nasa coincoin
qu'on avait en vérité
qu'est-ce que j'ai fait rire il faut
mettre un gardien oui c'est moi qui
avais moi alors dirigés respectivement
après cette évaluation de leur parler de
mon salaire est ce que tu es ce que là
c'est probant ou pas je pense que tu
mérites ta direction de france
télévisions presse locale a déplu train
coup on dit qu'on voit ainsi tu piges et
oui trinquons convoité quid s'éviter
lutrin quand on dit qu'on voit ce qu'on
vous envoie stupide a fait place de
fringues qu'on avait des gars je
comprends brett hull m ouais je laime
d'amour sur des îlots hygaard de tite
les jeux de 20 heures et le oui
policiers compagnons de la chanson la
quatrième étape celle en laine pie xii
chaque le 19/20 sont à 3 23 heures c'est
ce qui suppose que si ça marche quand
même c'est ça qui est dingue les gens
regardent ça ya en a sonné
j'ai répondu c'est qui mes compagnons la
chance semblait des compagnons de la
chanson je me suis fait [ __ ] la dictée
je te raconte pas bonjour thierry va
bien je sais pas quoi amener j'ai amené
mon sac
ouais voilà tu te mets là fille de
malaise la partition ça sera là après
12h tu vois ce que je veux dire quoi
autant que tu connaisses l'endroit ok à
la muscu ouais un petit peu ouais y'a
pas grand chose
dehors mais là c'est rien c'est dresser
au ritz ça va super le plaisir de te va
pardon et maître capello cela fait une
ville
je connais gym oui je connais gilles
bien sûr s'est vu déjà plusieurs feux
capello qui nous a fait une dictée jeu à
temps déjà je me suis planté comme
incombe défaut de la congère c'est moi
qui avais comment ça va jacques mon ami
jacques mon ami jean marie messier twain
et d'amis alors général jean-marie qu'un
tarif the thud le plein sur une tiare
l'appareil pour se prosterner devant
j'attends qu'il arrive quelque part on
va le faire mais on va le faire moi je
le faisais salut à toi grand jacques
juloux voilà comme ça mais tu dis salut
à toi grand public on va régler à mettre
un peu de chauffage
bonjour carlos merlos dit charles
hedrich a donc agi travailler avec
avec guy on pote avec mon pote dit ouais
mais tu vas tu as ton petit régime là ça
oui tu continue toujours son tir est
chaud parce que c'est pour la pour la
ligne à tous quoi un showman
donc je
oui mais je cours et je surveille
vachement parce que s'il me fait pas
maintenant
le stade de france il ya un moment où ça
s'en va se mettre torse nu tous vraiment
ça oh que oui je vois la différence 6 mt
whisky ouais moi je viens petit whisky
ouais t'as un truc toit pour dégraisser
un peu l'estomac cassure bien sûr à
vendanger c'est le trou normand avant
que c'est ce qui marche dans les deux
sens par un drop la vallée noyon la
balle est noyé la marine va pas parvenir
à malte
moi j'ai trouvé mieux dans la rousse de
redonner ambiance le jeu que je le gagne
1,1 et je reste ici sur soi mais c'est
d'une beauté
j'ai connu des revers mais qui contient
sont julien il savait tout le temps
comme ça arrive plus qu'on dise
trinquons mais convient un stupide si
nadine allez je m'approche tu vas pas
maintenant je je je je je suis juge
braun a pourtant mais quand je disais
c'est un combat contre je suis une merde
non moi je
moi que je trinque e jeudi du jour aller
à l'intelligence à monsieur sentez vous
n'avez déjà c'est pareil pour
connaissance faut dire stupide de
carburant comme un sens oui et puis
jouer ainsi ça ferait un truc terrible
voit le potentiel là au stade de france
honneur de déconner et quand j'apprends
études d'esprit qu'on a profité des
sprays s'en prenant ces le second thé
paix ont dit pas trop petit tapis
pis c'est génial et pascal sait quel
programme battait à thouars ça peut
partir que fais-tu des couples qui
viennent à toi et me répond je marie
c'est jean marie et jean marie ça c'est
pas un proverbe aléatoire ça veut pas ça
fait une dictée j'ai fait mais des
fautes à la maison pour des projets d
occurrence parfumé de ces 2 ra
occurrence ou un cm1 ou occurrence
non hein
c'est marie il va pas ainsi 1 est
bientôt deux décennies de sa récurrence
ne touche pas à toi ça vu que ça va bien
je fais d'habitude l'avenue capello l'a
pu
alors à vous ouais même été truc là
c'est la soirée c'est parti comme ça
c'est parti sur des dictées sur des
trucs c'est très calme jacques si vous
voulez bien voir une phrase une phrase
que je dis que moi c'est une saison
bleue adossée
heureusement je suis pas amateur qui
vivent à la rougeole est la clé de la
mienne c'est une imbécillité jaoui
jacques heures c'est une imbécillité
c'est une imbécillité car il va faire
cinq fautes là dedans tu vois pas être
sage il convient abc lité pour un
quincaillier way mère est sûr de son
coup fort pour bien articuler parce
qu'on va on voit pas les lettres l'a
tellement 1 kg que 8 pour un
quincaillier ce qu'il a dit il faut bien
articulé pour un quincaillier d'occire
un levraud occire tué d'occire à l'euro
deux héritières derrière un groseilliers
levraud eux a été tronquée un ace et
c'est drôle mais il ya de quoi faire 30
fautes dans à peu près rien c'est ce qui
nous a fait tout à l'heure c'est très
serré c'est une imbécillité pour un
atelier de schirrhein levraud derrière
j'aime et un choisi derrière un gros
ayez été or il va pas nous faire une
faute ce serait pour lui que je suis
content je matin que dark vador est pile
volta vous trouvez qui fait des fautes
de marivaux ou que oui à et prétentieux
sépare les gens c'est bon
le groseillier de i2 eli yshai er et la
faute sur abc pour ses mains pourquoi
pas ce qu'a décidé mais 2n et en 1798
thérapie un connard à 10,9 aucune que
cannelle pourquoi parce qu'il avait peur
qu'on prononce imbécile a concédé qu'il
maintient j'ai une question à vous poser
eux m non à vous m avant d'aller
beaucoup ont dit filles et pourquoi on
dit qui alors que ça finit par y 2 et le
les deux filles ville tranquille et
filles qu'il allait qui encore mieux ce
que c'est les mêmes les tranquilles les
quilles un quine et qui parce que y
avait il une ia j'ai fait deux ans de la
tentation
justement le profil du 10/01 touche pas
j'en serai jamais ta paye une villa à
percer ville la plaie quand on attend si
l'irak avec annie yahi yeux jacques
attend d'elle
vous allez voir il n'a jamais raté
jacques rogge a bien joué la pizza ici
dans un régime non je vais rappeler
anna grave yonhap alors au quatrième
étage et quatrième étages on va passer à
table a pas ce que tu as dit un
anagramme un télégramme une télégramme
on avait la ceni annoncés pourtant ça
finit par gramme l'e2c raison vraiment
rêveur bon allez taxi et d'un cabinet
non c'est le casting
alalalala cru que ça allait arriver mon
petit déjà comment ça va très bien
non hélas il se fait battre ici je
mouline toi ton cordages de fourrer
reconnaît marie claude bomsel
on cherche on s'occupe du jardin
d'acclimatation jardin des plantes
ces plantes les plantes y avait des
plantes tout la ménagerie du jardin des
plantes hajri du jardin des plantes
bon allez j'arrête
eh bien non allez
mal corrigé les fans des français
toi tu es si toi toi tu es là dans ma
vie si jeune bien laurent blanc
et
non ici voilà monsieur biya bliard ici
oui
monsieur lessard
jrue sur la bague
voilà monsieur daniel russo ici
c'est la maman n'est pas grave
et
mais oui non mais
vous raccompagner je dois accompagner le
nez je vais prendre votre carte l'année
24 valeo votre cas jim agate de monsieur
vélo et laurent
allez jacky ido jacques merci mon salut
j'ai acabit à toi bidon ouais j'ai un
taxi et attractions problème à la base
j'ai déjà geneviève va faire un dîner
chez thierry est tout à fait d'accord et
oui il y à qui j'ai dit baye à machin
mais elle émet tout le monde et puis
quand je dis à jean marie bigard et je
lui dis qu'il verra quel avant la fin du
repas tu adoreras jean marie est un
homme ou une crème de mec donc je
t'annonce et au début du repas qu'à la
fin du repas vous serez que les chemises
jaunes assure qu est ce que ça fait ça
tout le monde parce que c'est le plus
gentilles et des garçons moi ça m'est
arrivé c'est le plus gentil les garçons
parce qu'il ya des gros mots mais oui
j'aime bien la l1 pour deux vous laurent
vous l'avez connu commenté hard avec le
premier seulement le transformateur
moi je suis vraiment le gros buzz
vulgaire et lui il lui dit les singes se
met ça sur le cul
c'est déjà ça démarre mal oui criaient
vous avez pas vu passer une [ __ ] avec un
chapeau il faisait ça alors j'étais
levage et apparentés parler comme ça et
de ne pas respecter les personnes âgées
pour être ta grand mère et tous puis
après il a beaucoup regretté
moi non mais je n'ai consolide mois lors
l'histoire ce que c'est que je viens il
était dit que j'ai eu un très mauvais
jugement de geneviève et je pensais que
je ne viens avec une vieille conne et
donc je m'étais permis une bonne pas
très drôle un peu lapidaire et je ne
savais pas que geneviève est une femme
formidable que j'aime d'amour s creek
est mieux tiré que des potes
ok avec la joie est immense et dis le
elle a crié comme jamais à saint paul de
vence
j'étais au bord d'une piscine il ya et
d'un seul coup ya un gars qui est dans
la piscine et qui me fait c'est un cas
qui a joué dans neuf mois
jd oui il me fait on finit me fait chier
ils m'emmerde ma femme seule passe en
boucle est enceinte
vraiment vraiment que tu me fais chier
il se barre afin de gêner mais qui sait
ce mec
et puis d'un seul coup on voit le type
qui nagent qui revient et âme à fait
mais c'est ma fille qui fait si ma fille
tu es sûr que c'est pas fini je touche
c'est lui il revient au tribunal
il revient en fait on des jeunes j'ai
joué et on s'est plus quittés moi j'ai
eu plus de mal avec laurent que j'ai
rencontrés parce que il avait fait comme
geneviève au début me thrill me battre
ont calculé
c'est vrai j'ai insisté je vais appeler
tous les jours j ai fait des parades
amoureuses
non je l'appelais tous des vilains
s'étaient rencontrés avec il revient
chez guy lux e première émission de la
classe six mois en claquant sexy je
rencontre leur première rencontre et il
sort un sketch effet bravo les mecs ce
qui est le premier sketch que j'ai fait
jolo à la casse et
il y est c'est incroyable parce que je
dise oui qu'il avait une écriture
formidable tu es super pointu jamais vu
ça de ma vie mais j'arrivais de province
il ya un bris ggg leur jeu mais des
fleurs autour de chez lui tout le bordel
et de juste que je sais pas qui c'est
passé dans ce sens là je sais lire lui
et après et après c'est lui qui
repassait devant pressé dit merde ce
mec-là 6e
ces raisins ensemble mais sinon au début
calculez du tout c'est au qg l'appelait
tous les jours parce que j'avais fait un
sketch dont j'ai pu quitter et ses bas
ses six moines et j'ai trouvé leur nom
est aussi un jour j'ai fait un truc pour
le cas vous je me suis fait un peu
défigurée par un contre qui on va tirer
une balle à bout portant dans la gueule
donc je suis passé en chirurgie on va
gratter des grades des grains de poudres
et tous et ce type que je ne possède que
je ne connaissais pas m'a appelé pour
prendre de mes nouvelles et puis un jour
toi il m'a dit un truc juste hyper
gentil quoi et j'ai halluciné et je suis
passé du fait de dos de trouver lourdaud
et tout d'un seul coup je suis tombé en
amour de ce mec quoi mais ça s'est pas
démentie vous vous êtes connu comment
tous les deux moi je sais ce qu'il
appelle une fiche une émission de radio
sur fun s'appelait c'est quoi ce bordel
et l'on est ce que tu veux vas-y fais
nourrir vas-y vas-y fais rien et il dit
c'est ce que tu viens dans mon émission
et moi je lui dis bien sûr que tu embêté
parce que je suis pas trop le temps et
là il dit j'ai pas trop le temps conner
hurler de rire ajoute connard sinon ça
n'a pas d'impact mais il pas trop le
temps qu'on est vraiment ça c'est que tu
les appeler pourquoi parce que j'étais
drôle invité dans son émission une
émission à l'ensemble sur fun radio et
donc je suis allé dans l'émission sur
fun
il y avait il à fait téléphoner ma femme
qui m'a annoncé qu'elle était enceinte
qui faisait un génie pour savoir ce que
c'était qu'elle avait des jumeaux moi je
l'écris non plus étant là les gars
étaient et après il est venu me voir ici
je voulais qu'il écrivait
des trucs pour l'émission de petites
séquences et tout ça il m'a montré une
cassette formidable où ils allaient dans
la rue disait aux gens
il disait aux gens qui avaient des
blousons en skaï tv vous pouvons des
comptes à la maman sky sur la sur la
banquise les gens marchaient et jean
marché regarde ça j'ai construit changer
disait de vous pour les interroger les
gens debout pour les caméras de
surveillance dans les toilettes
publiques et les gens disaient ah bon
des caméras mais pourquoi rester bas
pour les la drogue les homosexuels la
sécurité est déguisé sécurité du monde
disait oui
êtes vous pour les parcomètres sur les
bancs publics etes-vous pour les
trottoirs fumée entre auteurs non
fumeurs c'était prémonitoire
il ya aussi un truc que j'aurais dire
qu'il me semble important vu que si
geneviève elle prend son pain à gauche
et que thierry pons ne semble pas un à
droite moi j'ai [ __ ] d'accord où tout
le monde prendra ta gueule et la famille
combien de films moi beaucoup toi
beaucoup ouais t'as trouvé des gens qui
d'ordinaire
j'étais j'ai un peu honte à le dire ce
que donne la veille trois français sur
comme ça mais je trouve je ne veux pas
parler de ça c'est fait un chantage
affectif pour que les gens viennent me
voir si le film marche
elle rit comme monsieur je me fais ça
marche très bien j'ai acheté mon disque
mais c'est pour le film sinon il va
vendre sa maison
il te dire aux gens et qui sait que je
suis je suis ne marche pas il ay moeurs
et sont tous les réalisateurs de tous
les films c'est à dire qu'ils ont battus
10 points mais j'en avais assez même pas
le real qui met en scène le producteur
l'oréal il est très content d'avoir fini
son film on voit mon premier exploit
c'est que j'ai signé mon film et que
c'était chaque jour on tournait en se
disant [ __ ] les échéances se
rapprochait c'était décembre où je mens
était de 2 2 millions de francs qu'il
trois puis quatre puis sept puis dix
voix et et on croit y avoir une pression
les pressions et lui la belle aux
chiffres élus qui t'envoient s'il est en
bois c'est parce qu'il arrivait le matin
il me balancer des chiffres matin donc
il faut la journée allait bien je dise à
quelque 400 km
ce que j'aime chez l'homme c'est guy
zitte pas nous partager ses angoisses et
du une fois que tout le monde est par
terre voilà à son réveil il se redresse
et dix bombes allez on y va maintenant
tout le monde est détruit détruit tout
le monde il est moins bien on aime bien
les champs de bataille est rude à chaque
tout le monde en parle en arrivant ici
je suis crevé ta mauvaise mine
le rôle de daniel a été tiré au sort tu
l'as dit ça a pris l'eau face à pile ou
face un bon parce que c'était moi qui
devais avoir le rôle comme ça on
attirait il a tiré la new faces ouais
ouais et celui qui est gagné comme quoi
ta nea les parties se cacher derrière le
rideau ouais elle choisit pas non mais
surface et derrière j'ai entendu pascal
il a été très fair play je n'aurais pas
pu la jouer réacteur principal d'un film
à pile ou face
on était sur la scène du jus de ces
suppliques du jeu de basse avant on
était sur la scène du gymnase et andy
comme vous êtes mes amis moi je prends
de problème je t'y rapide matters info
expliqué avant il ya huit ans j'ai écrit
le rôle pour pascal je connaissais pas
daniel à prendre a dit pascal n'est pas
connu donc j'ai pris daniel est un petit
peu connu on m'a dit ça va et alors
j'avais écrit des choses pour pascal est
un peu pour daniel et puis après j'ai
décidé de le produire avant je faisais
ce que ce que je voulais et je
n'arrivais plus à choisir entre pascal
et daniel c'était
je n'en ai plus qu'assez du corps et
voilà je l'aurais dit au théâtre je vais
arriver j'ai découvert les enfants je
les aime beaucoup mais j'ai envie de
dormir la nuit
donc on va tirer à pile ou face et la
promo alors le lot tu m'as pas raconté
bas la promo c'est capté par jour trois
radios le presse est jeune on a fait
rire et chansons ensemble
j'aimerais à la presse john key est donc
paix mais qu'il ce succès les en 2003
comme quand même temps je t'ordonne
autant qu'ils veulent mais ils sont pas
contents optionnellement il doit non
mais ya pas marqué bruce willis pour
l'instant donc tu sais moi j'anticipe a
donné sept mille et je trouve que deux
jours chacun reçoit à la maison ils
repartent avec du foie gras des produits
régionaux
c'est quoi comme aucun cd marouani ob
oui si c'est souvent moi j'ai pas le
droit
et en plus les chants des molles mayoral
marché du requin marteau d'un alors le
retient fait partie des cartilagineux
ouais pourquoi en retraite qu'on
retrouve pas de squelettes mariko de
requins gilson cartilagineux et que de
ce fait il ne se fossilise pas les
requins ne se fossilise pas parler dans
donc on n'a que des dents on n'a pas les
vertèbres n'apparaît comme les poissons
primitif j'adore l'arrêt oui on s'est
mariés mais je sais beau essayer de me
dire que je n'ai
alors si vous les avez avec les aime qui
a vu recherche ian griffin et le grès
vie voilà et le zèbre des montagnes sont
ici n'est pas pacifique c'est la voix
des montagnes et il est très efféminé
pour moi c'est une petite [ __ ] qui
va se cacher en acier pour toi pour lui
cela s'explique à mi-course a fait feu
en flou comme canal+ un peu les autres
animaux exactement par rapport à ces
prédateurs pour sa vie mais enfin c'est
quand même étrange que les tempéraments
en pleine savane et tout mais ce qu'on
pense que c'est une possibilité de
dissimulation et pour vous êtes les
débris a payé à partir du côté de
l'entrepôt d'un goût douteux
il voit plus rien comme canal+ excepté
assez de larmes c'est de l'art optique
quoi c'est une guerre façon parce qu'en
général ces personnes
en général ils se camouflent les arts
l'occurrence il est très visible
on dit que serré lieu c'est aussi pour
échapper à la mouche tsé tsé
c'est ce qu'on m'a dit ça c'est moins
sûr effectivement elle qui crée un
certain endroit et qu' ils ont des
rayures individuels comme on a des
angevins digital et appartient d'assumer
la mairie reconnaît les mamans grâce aux
veillées je sais d espèce de coup de
barre voilà un moment elle fait but
c'est le dieu rit ça c'est moins à moi
je voulais dire et geneviève que mes
gros mot oui même si lui déplaisent un
peu c'est comme les par rapport au
personnage fait partie le courage des
grandes claques dans la gueule et
coûteux a fini jean marc ayrault monde
c'est exactement le même on exactement
la même vocation que les paraboles qui
sont utilisés pour expliquer quelque
chose car télé tous les grands
5en hader et et thierry le premier dans
exemple est ce qu'on croit en dieu et
notamment moi par exemple j'adore jésus
parce que je veux c'est et le péché des
thèmes aussi oui je suis sûr que jésus
lui même ça mais c était le premier
dissidents il a été été crucifié pas
parce qu'ils disaient qu'il est ici avec
deux cent mille personnes par jour ils
venaient se présentèrent il en mangeait
juin pour l'audition du messie et d'eau
il était en fait s'il a été donnée non
seulement après aux romains qui n'ont
pas voulu parce que les le sanhédrin
voulais pas le tuer les romains ont dit
merde ce mec est vraiment trop d'amour
on peut pas le tuer dans qu'ils l'ont
donnée au peuple qui a voté et
finalement il a été tué par l'ensemble
de l'humanité c'est ça le message de
jésus
mais si ça s'est passé c'est qu'il est
il a dit au sanhédrin vous respecter la
lettre
vous êtes les gardiens de l'écriture de
respecter la lettre me vous trahissez
l'esprit de dieu
l'esprit de dieu est vivant dans le
coeur de chacun il n'est pas mort gravé
dans la pierre
c'est tout ce que je voulais dit elle en
parlant avec des paraboles ou en
évoquant des choses par exemple intimes
avec des tas de deux tonnes de billettes
couilles
des fois on arrive à faire comprendre
quelque chose aux gens d'une manière
plus claire avec des mots plus forts
on peut comprendre
jusqu'à ce que j'avais adoré c'est les
grandes causes et les pauvres aussi
notamment parce que là on est quand même
dans un dîner excuse moi thierry mais je
t'en prie on est loin de la faim dans le
monde l'afrique bordel nous un jour on a
écrit ça avec le jouet le lot il a
enfoncé le clou tellement loin que
j'étais presque injouable
je faisais et ça faisait ça faisait ça
la salle quoi mais ne pouvait pas les
gens ne pouvaient pas les gens dieu le
pauvre n'a aucun goût
aucun tu verras jamais une toile de
maître chez impôts alors qu'entre nous
un van gogh ou un petit picasso de la
période bleue c'est quand même plus
sympa kaka ne va pas bien présentes de
serre orange qui boivent dans une mare
sur un coucher de soleil violet à nous
c'est pas à chier partout ça leur plaît
pas y a qu'à regarder la femme du bord
ci est la bonne robe de chambre fleurs
avec des mules et des bigoudis plein la
tête
il touchera pas tu ferais jamais un
pauvre avec un top model jamais ça ne
m'intéresse pas
quand tu vois comme on est reçu au royal
de deauville s'est empressé charme aller
au camping de melun pour la même
distance un même regarde le pauvre l'été
il va passer dix fois devant une plage
privée magnifique et du sable fin et où
s'arrêtera jamais pour louer un matelas
de s'emballe il n'a pas le réflexe alors
que pour lui et sa famille c'est quoi
c'est un coût de 1200 balle mais
pourrait bien bordel et ben non alors
vous allez me dire c'est son budget
dresse même mais qu'ils soient bien il
va nous préférons être vie jour mal
qu'un jour bien donné à 56
de quoi donner quoi mes clés cnc importe
clic je ne pas tout le monde j'ai fait
ça pour un quatre contre
c'est non ça m'a fait pleurer j'ai
téléphoné le soir même vous avez excès
salle porte-clés à wigan il aime
beaucoup thalmann oui c'est super fowler
a choisi semprun et moi choisi jolivet
l'histoire ce qu'est parti 4e
mais je vous fais la laisser pénétré par
l'idée
sa véritable traquenard entendu une
femme il est très jeune vieux en était
à deux doigts de conclure reculer
l'échéance et c'est bien normal essayer
d'emballer j'ai passé riche et d'y
rester caresser des saintes ouais je ne
sais pas très bien de dire que telle
magnitude 6,6 c'est une trahison
surtout il vivait mal sa wii et voici
maintenant la wii est en fait si lui
devons porter plus franchement pourquoi
tu as donné pour tokyo je conseillerais
conscience annoncé que c'est sophie
thalmann qui crachent c'est moi enfin
sous trois jours
qu'est ce qu'il ya
qu'est ce qui se passe devant rien vous
êtes émules oui oui à cause de soucis je
te montrerai j'ai amené de trois
documents et je vais te manquer tu vas
matt kemp hier elle est rentrée à tf1
par la grande porte avec son booty pour
mac os miss france woods avait gros sur
le coeur
est ce que ces attaques aient accepté
mais gravier méritait pas ça les
remonter dans vous aurez là tu sais
faire comble oui michel lafon qui veut
faire mon bouquin toi ta vie à toi alors
je vais dire va brosser vous tient comme
si je vais faire un bouquet avec vous
vous avez fait le bouquin de tabra
michel lafon et qui délivre de tout le
monde non non non non moi j'ai besoin de
faire avec lui rarement vu comme ça elle
a fait mouche et non mais vraiment pas
ce que j'ai fait c'est parce qu'il me
doit tout se fait en poche et j'ai eu et
j'ai vraiment jamais rien eu avec elle
j'ai passé une bonne heure où je pensais
faire un livre comme ça peut cracher
dans la soupe
ça me paraît trop minable
quand il disait que moi j'étais une
radine c'est ce qu'elle a raconté va pas
voit deux tons et hôpital à la vieille
mois la boîte de thon et les biscottes
ouï dire que je viens chez moi je vois
tu de ton pour une personne c'est sympa
de tonnerre c'est sophie thalmann cécile
sophie thalmann selon ce qu'a écrit
envie chapelle l'envers du diadème et
puis d'abord elle a expliqué que j'aime
bien et erding dont l archevêché avait
lui donné du ton et les biscottes
elle a expliqué que le fils de geneviève
xavier de fontenay voulait pas lui
porter ccc pas garder on allait l'amener
à la gare de là je ne sais pas si
mougeotte hills ami à la gare de l'est y
est on est préparé son sac pour aller
prendre le train pour par le dubaï
course en sac mais moi je porte mon sac
quand j'ai quelque part ils portent
m'avait l'humour personnes portent
vanille ça veut dire quoi lui dire ça
pendant que votre grave
non mais je veux dire c'est débile mais
c'est en panne et riendeau c'est la
vraie vie avec la lie je veux dire c'est
pas très cher ça brille mais que les
médias monde
jean béliveau question c'est bon ça
c'est ce que michel lafon me dit il n'a
pas très bien marché et la démarche
devienne un des clubs
chère madame de fontenay
c'est avec un grand plaisir et tous mes
remerciements que les bouteilles d'eau
pour les bouteilles de vin que je vous
souhaite une très bonne année 99
j'espère pour vous serez toujours santé
et prospérité la famille entière lui
thalmann grands parents etc
on n'oubliera jamais tout ce que vous
avez fait pour sophie et espère pouvoir
un jour vous renvoyer l'ascenseur il est
resté bloqué une façon table est ton
film toi tu m'avais demandé une chanson
elle est dans le film j'ai perdu mes
clefs de bagnole
allez-vous ta chanson aidé à m'en faire
un bon ben c'est fantastique parce que
je les mêmes pamphlet mais tu l'as fait
au film oui on a signé pour toi on est
bons pelé tel café la chance un cbb
enfin chanson j'ai perdu mes crises
bayonne et qu'est ce qu'elle a ma gueule
s'arrêter faire il l'a fait son fils il
est vachement bien non mais les clefs de
bagnole c'est une blague c'est aussi cet
incident je voulais faire un album mais
finalement je me suis pris trop tard
parce que j'ai trouvé j'avais trouvé une
idée si j'avais perdu mes clefs de
bagnole je n'aurais jamais connu tu vois
les choses comme ça mais j'ai fait j'ai
poliment sincèrement j'ai pris là
combien de vedettes dans ton film ces
normes
une petite centaine je vais continuer à
tourner merci d'en tuer la figure de
proue geneviève
il a un casting en berne c'est qu'à un
moment il a quand même
il a quand même deux par dieu qui est un
fromage et sans aucune réplique
pas un mot pas moins intéressant rien du
tout et le saignement dans la bagnole et
du texte et qui aidé à mieux dit ouais
j'ai vu juste gérard depardieu mais ce
qui m'épate le plus c'est comment t'est
arrivé à voir une belette pareil été
oubliés on s'en branle et les au
générique on s'en fout qu'ils fassent un
fromage et je suis parfaitement acheté
du fromage pour ma mère est dit mais
c'est pas dans le scénario il m'a donné
son fromage
je pense que dans sa carrière il y aura
un avant et après le film gérer il sera
plus le même on verra plus depardieu de
la même façon de dire que quand tu lis
tu as dit qu'est ce que je fais et qui
lui a donné les deux pages de textes et
qu' il a regardé les deux pages et d'un
second en lisant il fait les regarde
l'aurais fait mais c'est lamentable et
laurent lui fait c'est exprès une heure
fallait qu'il parte à 11h30 ils
marquèrent 11h31 quelques nouvelles
cages lui une heure et ce jour là
j'avais besoin d'un seul accessoire un
pichet de lait de chèvre
ouais un pichet des laits de chèvre et
l'accessoiriste il a un accessoire
question sa fille de service et ils
l'oublient
et moi j'ai deux par dieu ce jour là
pour une heure donc c'est pour moi ça
fait des mois que j'attends ça j'ai
besoin juste la piche l de lait de
chèvre et il n'est pas là et j'ai
vieilli de dix ans qu'on n'était pas
dans le trou duc marie-claude on était
dans la sodomie pour une fois que j'ai
fait correct et d'utiliser le bon
c'est le sphincter le rectum dans la
chute où il m'a expliqué qu une [ __ ] la
base du dieu du globe où la peau est un
peu violence est là pour la pluie fine
qui a chez l'homme et la [ __ ] cas elle
rentre là le gland via y vient coincé
avec le rectum c'est ça qui est
vachement bon tu comprends et à ce
moment là ou à la base du rectum tous
les microbes sont là tous les virus et
viennent entre et en pression et en
contact avec la base millions
monté sur la sodomie valdés piqué un
truc énorme il a blanche le président
alain parler de toi qui rêvait te
connais maintenant c'est pas fini c'est
le deuxième effet kiss cool
à quel hacker le quel moment et comment
ça s'est passé ton émission c'était bien
oui c'était bien
c'est sympathique bande annonce et est
et ouest et en télévision sur les comics
ceux qui font rire des visas et pop sur
l art en plus ma part et de temps à
parler du du stade du nom du stade de
france poser les lits du bien je fais
maintenant on a bien on t'a bien taillé
un accord non m'a dit du bien à next est
de 18 c'est l'anniversaire de jamel
c'est drôle du pot tu tombes des
affaires des djebels un beau cadeau que
tu lui fais bah oui mais c'était une
vitre attention il avait eu comme ça bon
j'espère que ça fera plaisir
qu'est ce tu fais toi là moi je fais je
fais je tourne avec un talent en ce
moment tu tu tournes dans son film we
intime où je devais être
ouais y'a machin mon film mais brad pitt
ou je sais pas qui doit sa bonne idée
johnny da moi je les mélange tout parce
que j'avais alors en parler du film de
l'an vrai que c'est une belle merde
23 23
avec la salle apparaître 23,7 au chiffre
magique laurent ouais parce que c'est un
chiffre que j'aime bien que je dis
souvent mais quand jean marais à jouer
la scène où il y avait écrit 23 il a
hyper bien vendu et le lendemain je
voyais les machines au qui lisent f13 il
reprenait les adolescentes jean-marie et
je me suis dit ça c'est formidable c'est
chiant négation que jean marie a fait
j'ai tour
j'ai tourné à la presse ils se détestent
les deux c'est infernal
et donc j'ai enfoncé le clou jeudi à
alain de dia 23 pas tout le monde et 10
23 dans le film ce qui est
extraordinaire on était dans une ville
du trapel pendant la tournée est long
nous on voit occasion il y avait un 15/5
et laurent dit qu'il ya un petit billet
il fait vous me lisez sa soul man 3 et
pascal qui est quelqu'un d'honnête me
dis je vais quand même me jouer le 23
mars à gérer on est arrivé on arrivait
au casino géré on était en train de
changer l'argent et on entend les deux
cas là il faut changer immédiatement et
partir est ce qu'on a fait on la rejouer
tout de suite les deuxièmes plus 23,3
double
à
46 hockey
seysses
santander
si ces 69 derrière ses 69 ans je me
connais c'est ma spécialité
bagnols au crayon l'afp enrique yeves
très droit
25 et qui nécessiterait un bolivien là
tu vas chanter moins fort je pense que
c'est barcelone il a commencé par panini
a mué et pas de voisins au dessus qui
visait un 4e étage chérie tu vas ouvre
un portable tu ouvres la porte gobelets
gérardmer canaux messieurs du dessus se
passera 10 à 20 jou lindbergh
je
m
la mer rouge tout
d
j
est ce que tu veux quoi comme l empire
ans
annie cordy de toilette
on se rassurera
tiens il est certain que tu veux
sans les impôts
mais la glace
bravo messieurs ont fait revenir les
pieds vissés canada ici
jamais qu'est ce que ça te fait de
grands pas de geneviève de fontenay
je la kiffe franchement j'adore tous ces
gens qui croient qu'elles sont bien ils
sont bien silimane bio des jeunes vient
de prendre
d'ailleurs j'aimerais bien qu'on aille à
un jour à mener mais miss la bad en
tenant lieu là bas c'est pas une
tendance à plus avant la députée de
vraiment les jolies de cervelle et tout
ça la touche au savoir est ce que
j'avais vu pas pris
je veille à ce que tu fais pour les
jeunes je sais que c'est contre ma
religion et je voudrais bien je suis en
vie je suis obligé de vous prévenir si
on buvait de l'alcool jusqu'à 20 grammes
en faire d'accord c'est vrai le plafond
va s'ouvrir et pas les clous
c'est vous qui décidez parce que ça je
me décharge - chaloupe à la mi journée
organisée peut-être un sou quelque chose
à dire et a mené les miss la mission
rentrer chez moi de l'avoir pour père
jean d'abord la radio gagnant va
s'organiser message un baigneur ses
péchés les bananes le mec qui va toucher
le maître adam en nous qui sommes de la
profession et enfin le stade de france
18 chanteraines à maracana le jour de
l'anniversaire le jour de ton
anniversaire grc a été démis face à face
à anelka tôt c'était pour te rendre
hommage shape a commencé alors que toi
la première c'est le jour de la
ménopause aux jeunettes gars
jamais je serai chanter 52000 personnes
j'irai bon maintenant je vais vous dire
maintenant c'est pour l'anniversaire de
jamel
et bah c'est pour tuer le spectacle tu
le connais par coeur le bien ouais ça
commence à rentrer ouais non non je
m'amuse vraiment je peux indiquer au
début parce que ça faisait longtemps
mais c'est comme le vélo bizarrement je
te jure que youtube
c'est la première date après tout
combien la vie de 20 minutes 3 rendra
quant au spectacle est en cours
d'élaboration
non non vous l'écrit ce que je dis là je
l'aï jamais dit avant quand je dis
jamais jamais dit avant j'avais jamais
allé jusqu en spectacle comme ça donc
comme ça que ça me permet un petit peu
même si je me trompe ou si jamais
d'ailleurs jeudi
si j'ai un trou je vous préviens j'ai
trouvé une technique américaine je crie
4 ou frère karim et qui ne s'oublie pas
le problème c'est qu'une hâte d'être
ambitieux non non ça se passe bien c'est
où ça sent le 23 décembre au casino 23,3
un chiffre deux films je regarde regarde
c'est imagine ainsi robert nommé robert
on a causé un peu joué le 20 août où la
chanson thème du film de bout en bout
pire ce qu'on peut doubler on peut
doubler c'est la musique en ré c'est la
musique du film de l'an on vient
d'écrire ce soir c'est la langue qui
scella eli lilly à said juste la
grand-mère qui avaient cliqué sur un
fauteuil roulant et petit chat qui joue
avec la balle alors j'ai joué avec la
balle la balle tape d'une bougie en doji
elle roulera sous les rideaux les
rideaux se mettent à brûler des
perroquets qui est vachement intelligent
comprend toi que la maison va brûler
notre échiquier là il dit il dans ses
cages et comme il est très intelligent
yb avec son bec qu'il ouvre la porte de
la cage
ils se penchent d'europe 1 2 m 50 s'il a
jamais volé depuis huit ans et ont pillé
chivet tu vas y vivent à plein temps
comme une merde en garde les rideaux
qu'équilibré rien la grand mère il
attrape le fauteuil de rire avec son bec
qui tire la grand-mère dans la chambre à
côté ferme la porte avec son bec et rome
sur le lit pour une couverture est
bourré couverture en batch pour le
souhaitait parce qu'il est très
intelligent et tout le président garde
ceux qui prendraient ces brûle un peu
les plumes cause il fait ça que ça va il
va bien selon edith les pompiers
téléphone les pompiers pensent pompiers
il aurait eu dans ce long que ça tenait
un médecin sur le but feuilletons y
prend son élan quand cinq pattes
s'accroche au premier
le premier tiroir mais la patte sur le
2eme 3eme d'arriver au téléphone et
regarde le cadran mais comme elles
commettraient intelligence vient 18 les
pompiers 18
il a fait tomber le combiné comme ça 18e
choix intelligent et attendent un coup
alors les pompiers
et comme il est très intelligent il sait
qu'il faut pas parler m
à l'endroit où on entend vous parlez de
l'autre côté ok oui c'est qu'il se met
de le noter il fait il est mon cocon il
en fait un magnifique
je crois que j'ai fait ce qu'il fallait
pour mémoire un coup de jeune
j'en ai une encore plus long hall a
conclu un avis porte-avions américain
qui arrive à terre-neuve zone canadienne
et puis voile lumière la nuit qui
s'avance vers lui dis ok nous sommes un
navire américain nous de vous demandons
de dévier de 5 degrés vers l'est le
canadien répond nous sommes un navire
canadien nous exigeons que vous déviez 5
degrés vers l'ouest l'américain répond
vous nous avez mal compris nous sommes
un porte avions deux des strikers devant
deux derrière 20 f 18
nous exigeons immédiatement et même
plutôt si possible que vous déviez 5
degrés vers l'ouest le canadien répond
nous sommes chez nous on sait ce qu'on
fait on vous en donne de dévier de 5
degrés l'américain répond le seul qui
nous ordonnent et de soldes qui on prend
des ordres c'est george bush
le canadien répond aux bonnes chances
nous sommes un phare
toute l'histoire celle là mais c'est
bien mais c'est une bonne idée le piano
totalisent un peu l'ambiance avant plus
où ce sera le genre de toi tu nous dis
garde du défilé par da il joue du jazz
aussi non la finale jamais le piano ça
l'est déjà mais aux gentilles chansons
très connues de paris charles aznavour
je reviendrai jamais en reste dans 70
des rabais avec une seule main je vous
préviens n'a rien à voir que le peuvent
pas
neuf points de vente
m
là
c'est pour aller se coucher
dans mon lit
je vois ma vie
les yeux fermés
mon
j'entends des voix j'ai connu
que gm
c'est la plaie le ya trop de monde dans
mon oreiller
dans ces lignes endormi
non
lee ancré au lac
ado
au tabernacle réponse la bête à deux dos
ce soir là les blessures d'amour comme
un soleil
j'ai pas sommeil jmal tempo avec mes
orteils
et jean bouin
sur les chevaux le chagall les taux de
picasso et que syfy de dali
c'est plus que dans mon cas c'est je te
vois quand tu jouais
et
mais bon
merci c'est vrai que c'est quoi ça y est
très bon à ce culte 1,2 point moi je te
jure j'ai beaucoup de mal à west ham a
pas connu d'internet comme ça c'est cool
quand j'étais jeune je t'ai comme seule
fois j'ai menti déçu boivent
c'est cool c'est que ce gars cool et
pour être sûr de ne rien rater de linda
hardy tube abonnez vous je m'étais un
peu ce bleu